it was so amazing during the commercial
break you got a lot of you got up and
started mingling and talking to each
other because you had to see each other
in a while well not you your office but
but for the most part but the best part
you were mingling and talking and then
we started shouting and I was saying
wait a minute wasn't then the show just
stuff like two years ago you said it's
been five years yeah that blows my mind
it's been that soon here's brightening
yeah we're all rocking the grave tone
and I still show up for work
[Laughter]
you're there for work he shows up so
there's time you with a good work ethic
that really care we keep showing up all
you gotta do yeah all you gotta do is
fly to Albuquerque and those killed what
about okay where you just brought up you
just brought up deaths RJ there were 270
deaths on the show 270 deaths on the
show you had an idea for another that
you pitched and it didn't go it is that
right I kind of pitch they were talking
about killing someone I said well jr.
you going to kill you said kill jr.
there's a game about that right who
would kill jr. I always hoping someone
good someone had to be good their cousin
the cousin Lewis and Danny moncada
I was like I was assuming because I read
it and I was like oh my part I don't
have a lot in any of this script you
know all the season I'm like oh man I'm
like losing I'm losing lines and then
these guys show up yeah I'm like wait
I'm this yeah you thought you were a
goner I've no one safer well no one was
safe on this show so okay this brings a
good good question because Vince did you
ever did you ever even think about
getting rid of our disco did you ever
think about it I did actually I
that's insane I know by the way and who
was gonna who was gonna kill him you
know and that part we hadn't figured out
but by the way you realize you want you
to once you get killed you don't get
paid anymore right so then I didn't know
you were hoping for every year contract
yeah but I was at the gym Carlos yeah
it's not true yeah early on I pitched to
my writers I had this idea where Walter
jr. there's this horrible you know he
gets killed by this nasty guy that Walt
is somehow in business with and I had
this whole thing why it would take too
long to even picture and all my writers
look to me like I was had completely
lost my mind it was a most horrible
person or people would have I don't
think people would have accepted not
writing murder I know you know they'll
say and enough people tell you you're
drunk you need to sit down my writers
essentially told me I was drunk
yeah and you've been drinking now yeah
you